dieser von dem südafrika ist wirklich
eine sensation die rede ist von einem
stand fragment das sich jetzt als die
älteste abstrakte zeichnungen der
menschheit entpuppt hat eine art hashtag
73.000 jahre alt bestehend aus roten
linien auf einem stein fragment
forschungsteams sind sich sicher diese
malerei ist mindestens 30.000 jahre
früher entstanden als alle bisher
bekannten zeichnungen unserer vorfahren
alle wichtigen facts zu diesem
spannenden fund bekommt ihr jetzt
herzlich willkommen bei diesen science
fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts wussten wir dass
schon die neandertaler vor 64.000 jahren
kunst schufen beispielsweise schmuck und
höhlenmalereien es gibt sogar hinweise
darauf dass selbst der homo erectus also
vor urzeiten muster in muschelschalen
gesetzt haben könnte forum vorstellen
waren 500.000 jahren jetzt gibt es neue
erkenntnisse dazu um einschätzen zu
können wann dieser entscheidende schritt
in der geistigen entwicklung des
menschen stattgefunden hat besonderes
augenmerk dabei liegt natürlich auf den
menschen dem homo sapiens wann wurde er
zum künstler wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler hatten bisher lediglich
höhlenmalereien aus europa entdeckt die
so etwa 40.000 jahre alt sind diese
gelten bislang als die ältesten
bekannten kunstwerke unserer vorfahren
keine hinweise konnten bisher dazu
gefunden werden ob der homo sapiens mit
der abstrakten malerei erst nach seiner
auswanderung nach europa begann oder ob
er diese fähigkeit schon in der urheimat
afrika entwickelt hatte
doch mit diesen rätselraten ist jetzt
schluss denn ein fund der bereits vor
sieben jahren in der sogenannten block
board höhle etwa 300 kilometer von
kapstadt entfernt gemacht wurde hat sich
jetzt als sensationelle entdeckung
wirklich herausgestellt denn das
steinfragmente dass ein forschungsteam
aus norwegen ausgegraben hatte ist
verziert mit einer zeichnung zumindest
im weitesten sinne
konkret wurden auf dem stein stück neun
linien entdeckt vier davon bilden eine
raute eine art hashtag also die anderen
der mit ocker gemalten linien kreuzen
sich zum teil bzw verlaufen para
die untersuchungen des forschungsteams
haben jetzt ergeben dass sowohl die
linien als auch der stein so um die
73.000 jahre alt sind somit sind die
muster auf diesen steinen mindestens
30.000 jahre früher entstanden als die
bisher bekannten malereien des homo
sapiens und stellen damit die wohl
älteste bekannte abstrakte malerei der
menschheit dazu dem ist sicher der stein
wurde durch menschen in seiner form
gebracht und mit ocker pigment angemalt
dazu heißt es in der untersuchung die
breite der linien spricht dafür dass sie
mit einem acker stift mit 1,3 bis 33
millimeter breiter spritze gezeichnet
wurden
das abrupte ende aller linien an den
kanten des stadtparlaments zeigt zudem
dass sich dieses muster ursprünglich
über eine größere oberfläche erstreckte
das muster war wahrscheinlich noch
komplexer und strukturierte als auch
dieses bruchstück erkennbar und für die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ist auch klar dass diese muster nicht
durch zufall bei einer anderen tätigkeit
unserer vorfahren entstanden sind
stattdessen handele es sich tatsächlich
um echte zeichnung die mit voller
künstlerische ambitionen auf den stein
gemalt wurden dazu das forschungsteam
das zeichnen war demnach schon von
73.000 jahren teil des verhaltens
repertoire des frühen homo sapiens in
südafrika und nicht nur das das
forschungsteam hat weitere opfer
stückchen identifiziert und auch dort
sind ähnliche muster eingeritzt auch das
des spannende schlüsse auf die geistige
entwicklung unserer vorfahren so dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher
christopher venture wird der frühe homo
sapiens nutzte demnach schon
verschiedene techniken um grafische
muster auf unterschiedlichen medien zu
erschaffen hammer es ist immer wieder
spannend sich all diese ereignisse und
wann sich stattfanden vor augen zu
halten wann lebten die dinosaurier waren
die mamut one besiedelt europa wer sind
unsere vorfahren
ständig gibt es dazu neue erkenntnisse
und wenn ihr kein video dazu verpassen
wollt dann abonniert auch den englischen
kanal von pixum denn auch da gibt es
videopremieren dafür einfach hier
draufklicken und da drunter geht es
weiter mit mystery of the alien man
irritiert ich hoffe wir sehen uns auf
dem englischen kanal einfach hier oder
da drauf klicken
stay tuned